hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday and that is
obviously the normal weekly dev stream
recap except today's a little bit
different because obviously with the
release of season 4 there isn't really a
lot of news after a season releases at
least on the next upcoming dev stream
maybe the next two but for this instance
there wasn't too much but there is a few
little things I do want to talk over and
then we can discuss those at the end so
let's get started with that first up
regarding the duel tournament the season
3 ranked tournament ornaments that we
get are still obtainable and you can
also obtain these on top of the season 4
ornaments that they just released if you
win a final you are guaranteed the
season 4 ornament with the hero that you
win the final match with so let's say
for example I played the entire
tournament with warden then it decide to
swap to raider in the finals I will get
the ornament for raider and not warden
you also have a chance of getting a
season 3 ornament as well at the same
time on top of the season 4 ornament so
you can actually get two for one win
next up was the progress about dedicated
servers they recently did a test they
said during the stream and it went super
well so that means they're gonna they're
also gonna be keeping us up to date with
the progress and hopefully dedicated
servers will be coming soon and then
lastly for this there was a couple known
issues that they're aware about one of
them being shamans pounce tracking
issues they're gonna be coming in a next
patch obviously if you guys have played
shaman against shaman or with shaman you
know that her pounces has weird tracking
issues I've had a few instances where I
pretty sure I've dodged the attack yet
she somehow magically attaches on to me
so that's hopefully going to be fixed
next patch she goki's demon embrace
range was shortened due to a side effect
of fixing a collision issue with the
move this is also going to be fixed next
patch peacekeepers infinite zone has
also been being worked on as well season
pass colors are going to be implemented
for the new heroes I noticed that on
reddit that are Musha and shaman didn't
get the season pass colors so that's
going to be implemented soon and then
also some of the players have been
complaining about the level 3 bots being
too difficult for their skill they're
going to be addressing this so that they
only appear for experienced players and
to end it I also noticed that somebody
in the comments of I believe yesterday's
video didn't mention this so this is a
fix for you there was a low FPS issue on
laptops since the new patch on for honor
PC there
working on this at the moment but for a
workaround you're going to need to go
into windowed mode or windowed
borderless so for the one person I saw
in the comments that had a trouble with
that that's your fix go to window two or
windowed borderless and that's really it
but once again this is a this was a very
short stream there wasn't a lot of
information because season 4 had just
released with the [ __ ] ton of loads of
content hopefully next week we're gonna
be getting some new stuff maybe a new
patch or some other ideas of what's
coming up next
but either way with that I just want to
ask you guys a question I'd love to know
in the comments below what you guys
think about season 4 what are your
thoughts on season 4 it did you let do
you like it do you not like it what do
you like and dislike about it I'd love
to know we could start a discussion in
the comments below so feel free to
comment what you liked or disliked about
season 4 but either way regardless that
is going to be the end of the video once
again sorry for being so short like the
video if you guys did enjoy this short
video subscribe if you're new to my
channel for more for content I cover the
news the leaks the discussions and the
patch notes of for honor and all that
good stuff my two most recent videos
will be on screen it is about the new
brawl map that was recently discovered
somebody popped this up on right at
using a glitch and they happen to find
this new map called brands guard and
then my discussion about whether shaman
would be considered overpowered at this
early stage of season 4 I would love it
if you guys both checked out those
videos both gave likes did all that good
stuff for me I'd really appreciate it
and with that guys I hope you have a
great rest of your day and peace out
guys take it easy